d'une pierre deux signatures pour israël
au moyen-orient les émirats arabes unis
et bahreïn s'apprête à conclure un
accord de normalisation de leurs
relations avec l'état hébreu
ces deux états arabes ont un point
commun politique avec tel-aviv leur
animosité envers l'iran mais cette
nouvelle alliance aura tout d'abord une
dimension économique dans une région où
les enjeux liés aux hydrocarbures
tiennent une place importante la
signature se fera sous l'égide des états
unis à la maison blanche une opportunité
politique pour donald trump à la peine
dans les sondages à moins de deux mois
de l'élection présidentielle
complètement normalisé leurs relations
diplomatiques
ils vont mettre en place des ambassades
et des ambassadeurs établir des vols
directs entre leurs pays c'est un jour
vraiment history un coup politique aussi
pour benyamin nétanyahou les
manifestations pour la démission du
premier ministre se multiplient depuis
des mois dans le pays
ses détracteurs lui reprochent sa
gestion de l'épidémie de coronavirus et
son procès pour corruption
l'aboutissement de ces accords est aussi
une manière de reconquérir l'opinion
tout accord de paix est une chose béni
surtout avec un pays musulman ou un pays
arabe
nous savons que pendant longtemps les
pays musulmans n'ont pas reconnu israël
à se sont opposés à nous et ont toujours
essayer de nuire à israël par des moyens
diplomatiques ou autre donc chaque
accords de paix conclus avec ces pays
dit qu israël est un pays légitimes y
compris aux yeux du monde musulman
les palestiniens eux vivent ces accords
comme une trahison
les états unis et israël cherche à
établir des relations avec des pays
périphériques qui n'ont pas de rapport
direct avec l'occupation israélienne
afin de promouvoir l'idée d'une paix
régionale comme alternative à la paix
palestino israéliennes
alphan manas à la tête de l'ofii là où
l'ayatollah robbie il y un changement
dans les priorités arabe
ce changement remplace israël comme
menace à la sécurité nationale arabe par
un autre ennemi qui est l'iran et cela
signifie l'abandon des obligations
envers la cause palestinienne
des manifestations sont prévues ce mardi
dans les territoires palestiniens pour
dénoncer ces traités considéré par les
dirigeants comme un coup de poignard
dans le dos jusqu'à présent les deux
seuls pays arabes ayant signé un accord
bilatéral avec israël sont l'egypte et
la jordanie